c'est à l'intérieur de ces pochettes
soigneusement conservés aux archives
départementales que se trouvent les plus
anciens documents administratifs de la
réunion comme ce registre d'état civil
qui recense le premier acte de baptême
d'un enfant noir
le 29e de juin 1669
je soussigné prêtre de la congrégation
de la mission est baptisé solennellement
en la chapelle de mascarin pierre diane
finale n'auront fils de dian b et de
rennes fiamma gaza
c'étaient les verts sont noirs du pays
d'ans boulot le parrain et monsieur rené
leveaux chirurgien de la compagnie des
indes orientales
natif de bayonne sa marraine madeleine
de l'homme d'orléans beaucoup de
documents qu'ils proviennent de fonds
publics ou privés passent par l'atelier
de reliure et de restauration depuis
près de 40 ans norbert berthe il
restaure ses écrits vieux de plusieurs
siècles est souvent marquée par le poids
des années
sa voix n'est qu'un mauvais état c'est
l'oeuvre des cas rial livre a été dévoré
par les car l'ia ou alors lesquels mais
c'est le même résultat de les avoir
charge de restaurer ces documents et
ensuite pouvoir donc les rendre dans le
c'est que des communications dans tous
les documents sont restés au regard bleu
bien sûr sauf qu'il faut c'est télé
beaucoup de patience pour un libertaire
murs ont depuis toujours par leur
arrivée à restaurer un document quel que
soit l'état du document les parties mois
quand ceux ci l'ont peuplée où peut pas
non plus inventé ce qui montre mais le
but de la restauration c'est de
récupérer le vestige qui reste médias
qu'on va débrancher le livre d'abord
feuille par feuille qu on va procéder
par mettre en page pas des ascidies film
à pied et en même temps par enlever la
moisissure dans un produit fongicide à
la fois on se doit les mettre ces
documents à sécher on va les combles et
on va les rues doublé par le procédé est
en collage qu'on appelle le doublage en
papier japon pour permettre que de moi
de retrouver une résistance mécanique
solidité depuis septembre 2001
tous les documents sont conservés dans
ce bâtiment des archives départementales
à saint denis
le public peut consulter sur place une
grande majorité de ces sources écrites
iconographiques et sonore qui
constituent le patrimoine historique de
la réunion j'aurais tellement c'est un
public de généalogistes nous avons aussi
un fort public qui vient faire des
recherches foncières pour retrouver les
actes de propriété sur les terrains
ensuite nous avons les professionnels
qui cherchent des documents officiels
soit des actes de naissance
tout autre document et puis nous avons
aussi un public de professeurs
d'historiens de chercheurs qui viennent
dépouiller les archives pour faire des
travaux de recherche qui permettent de
faire avancer les connaissances les
archives départementales ont pour
missions de
collecter de classe et de conserver de
communiquer de valoriser les archives du
département
c'est à dire les archives des services
déconcentrés de l'état
les archives du conseil départemental
les archives des officiers publics et
ministériels comme les notaires et sous
forme de dépôts les archives des
communes qui le souhaitent
nous accueillons également des archives
privées par voie de dons dépôt un choix